i love yonko because it feels like home
i feel a connection here with my
childhood and with my family and with my
people for sure i feel like that's a big
part of my
identity is my native culture so it's
really important to me to have that
in my life and to be able to
fall back on that in my in my daily life
and to have that as a part of me
my name is iona brown and this is my dog
rosie
i am honest koos in komo makalapuya the
coos side is from coos bay oregon and
califoria is from right here in the
willamette valley in yankala
we are komema kalipuya which is the
southernmost yankala tribe so this is
the homeland of our people
we are reviving the kalapio language
which was thought to be a dead native
language in oregon
me and my family are the only speakers
in the entire world and we are basically
studying our hearts out to try to bring
back our language which is a vital part
of our culture
i think a lot of people think nowadays
that native people either aren't around
anymore
or
people think of this stereotypical
native with long black hair living in a
teepee
i would just want the world to know that
native people are still here
we're probably not what you see on tv
and our culture is something that is
beautiful and sacred
so i definitely think that sharing our
culture
with the community is definitely a big
part in keeping our culture alive
there are very few storytellers anymore
it's kind of almost a lost art
one of my jobs my duty is to pass along
what i know
to the younger generation
just as my grandmas my elders my aunties
did with me to pass that along and trust
me with it and over the past few years
that's what i've been trying to do
with
the grandchildren
so it's it's important that the next
generation learn just as i learned
history is important so that you know
who you are and where you came from
and that's why the storytelling is
important because
the stories bring that history to the
present we still live that history and
firmly believe in the old beliefs and
even practice some of the ceremonies
that were important to us
when we drum it's a
it's a feel good thing for us it's the
time for us to get together and have
some really deep thoughts and feelings
and it's a safe place to do that
i had long ago
almost given up hope of ever hearing the
caliph language spoken
one of the things that i really grew to
to want really bad
was to learn the language the language
of my mother's people
and i it was almost hopeless for a while
so my grandmother met paul who was a
linguist locally here in oregon through
mutual friends and
he had been
collecting the caliph language for a
while now when he first encountered the
caliph words he said it was the most
beautiful language you'd ever heard
basically he came to our family and just
asked us if we wanted our language back
and of course we said yes because we
didn't really think that was possible we
had been told it was a dead language
it's been an unbelievable journey
starting from
just a few scattered words that i knew
within my family
to actually being able to look at a
sentence or at a
a bunch of words in a book and
and know what those words mean
that that has been just incredible for
me
so if i were to say
tatsumenhoy you would say um okay um
it's going to cost a little bit to get
these dictionaries printed so we've
started the fundraising process and
we're hoping that through this
fundraising we can
get the first copies of the dictionary
printed we're hoping to give these
copies out to
universities who study languages family
members of the tribe so with all the
fundraising we're doing we're trying to
print more copies get more resources and
get the books spread out to into as many
people as we can
i'm very proud of iona because she is
taking responsibility for being a
carrier of culture it's kind of sad but
saying my grandparents get older it's
definitely awakened me to realize this
is really important and this is
something that
i want to cherish and i need to cherish
show that eventually one day i can show
my kids and pass on all of these
traditions
[Music]
hi my love my name is curly i am a video
content producer over at buzzfeed we
wanted to bring you here today to bring
you a little surprise for all that
you're doing
so zell is sending you three thousand
dollars to help you on your journey and
to help you reach your goals and thanks
to zell the money will be in your bank
account in minutes
oh thank you so much and i mean thank
you and buzzfeed and everyone here for
coming out and helping us share our
story and share our word it's definitely
going to be a an amazing thing for us
and our family and our culture to be
able to spread our word like this of
course
thank you bye my love
i just found out that zell is sending us
three thousand dollars to help with our
project
wow that's pretty cool
it's so great that people are getting
behind this project yeah
good job gurley thank you excellent love
you love you
so you're now officially in charge you
have a question though yeah
what is that
i'd see i told you i told you she was
gonna ask
was that what goes into my bank account
within minutes
oh wow okay